in the early days of me doing this you'd
get these people who would say oh I
don't like that I like real instruments
real you know I like real things and I
was like well how do you define real is
if something uses electricity does that
make it not real because in fact we're
electric you know whenever you have the
slightest thought immediately electrical
impulses go from your brain through all
your nervous system to talk to your hand
and cause you to to to reach for
something or to jerk back because it
feels uh you've touched something that's
too hot or anytime you do anything any
effort with your muscle generates
electricity so
um real or natural is kind of like a
meaningless construct in my opinion
um so uh but I do understand that some
people think that using Electronics or
using technology
um is somehow cold and not human and it
can be it just depends on Whose hands it
is but if you think about technology
some of the most sophisticated
technology came before we started using
digital and electronic stuff like if you
just think of like the piano Forte
that's an incredibly sophisticated
techno techno a piece of technology that
people use to play music with you know
um and I imagine that there was a time
when people were like no plectrums are
better this weird thing with all these
levers and Hammers and it is unnatural
you know I'm sure that people thought
that when when those were new
um so anyway what I'm trying to say is I
think what makes art human is the human
that's creating it and it's not so much
the matter of what the tools that
they're using but how they use them and
what they do with them and but I do
understand I mean I'm not naive I do
understand that for a lot of people the
work probably seems a lot warmer to them
just because I'm in it and I'm a body
I'm a warm body and I sing and I make a
vocal sounds and and I do physical
gestures that might seem you know very
human to to them
um and that that's always in combination
with the technology that I'm using so
I'm always getting that comment from
people like oh well your your electronic
music is is nice because it feels more
human it feels warm to me
um but there's plenty of gorgeous music
that's being made by artists who don't
use their own bodies in in it other than
to stroke a trackpad or twiddle a knob
and still they create these really
moving
um beautiful soundscapes and and
textures and timbres and
use speaker arrays to surround people
with really even sometimes very organic
feeling
uh sound uh pieces and so on and so
forth so I think it's all about the
actual nature of the work itself